Họ biết như thế này, tất cả mọi người đã nào mình xin ra đều tốt người bị tất cả mọi người đã nào
Bây giờ, tất cả mọi người xin ra đều tốt người bị tất cả
Thế hoa gì có cả năng và nửa?
Thế li, tôi rất là nạn như nămu yên trong chiếc bơi tôi được tập về quan, năng lộn của bà, bất cứ
Tôi rất là nạn như trước đây, tôi không biết có chuyện này và hôm như không ai biết
Bởi bạn khi mất tửa mạng không nói, tôi chỉ nó
Để từ các mình không nghĩ là đúng là mạng có nhiều điều quan hình yêu
Con rất nhiều điều khi trải có nhiều điều để đi sống nó có phía tịch sáng mấy
Đến phục lưu chức của ra mình tơi được đọc bây bạn
Cậu tựng một đọc bước năng hành kia quời
Đi tôi hãy đúng đọc như thế này
Và tôi đối chếu với bạn biết anh
Mà bà lấy đi vô tên bà chỉ trả thì đúng là như vậy
Đi bà có đưa ra cái rật chứng là một chắc năm sau
Năm 1 miền tạm trong bây đi vô, á tạm trong cây bý sấu
Người ra đêm, đả nấu với có chuyện gì mà
Và năm 1 năm sau năm 1 miền chỉ là 1 hành kia quốc
Hình người phúc nước miền với có chuyện gì mà